hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 1 of his work on duties where
Cicero is presenting us with stoic moral
theory he's going to talk about four
main sources of the right of the hone
ask them that which is good
intrinsically that which reveals to us
the nature of our duties the first of
these is wisdom but the second of these
is justice justice understood in a
rather broad sense so justice understood
as a particular virtue as' disposition
and including a bit more than what we're
going to usually talk about as strict
justice so what is involved in in this
source of our moral duties
Cicero talks about a number of things
first he tells us that this is a virtue
that as he says maintain society and the
what we're translating often is common
bonds right these things that hold us
together literally it's a community toss
of Vita a commonality of life together
so society our common life together what
does it take to actually have something
like a viable community not just a bunch
of individuals each of them out for
themselves but people who are living
together so Cicero is going to tell us
that there's really two main sides to
this there's justice itself in terms of
which we call a person a good person and
and this is we can think of it as
justice in its strictest sense but then
very closely allied to it and involved
in this virtuous disposition is what he
calls by a number of different names and
we're gonna look at several of these a
little bit later he talks about Benedict
enti which we can translate as benefit
since sometimes it's translated as
charity sometimes a little bit you know
wrongly as benevolence a benevolence
really has to do with the will rather
than the doing or the making the factory
in this case and he says that another
way of talking about this is big Nick
neat item or libero Riley I taught them
that is kindness or generosity and these
are good ways to understand that as well
so both of these actually further this
this need for maintaining society and a
common life together it's not ok it's
not enough just to observe the rules you
might say and to refrain from violating
anybody's rights or any sort of strict
justice we also need this other aspect
but we're going to talk about that in
another place
so what falls under this notion of we
might say justice in the strict sense or
in the proper sense social wrote talks
about five main big headings in the the
section where he is describing this to
us in in book 1 and he devotes a lot of
space to it he tells us that there's
really two you know sort of primary you
might say not locations but but sort of
subdivisions of the duties involved with
justice these are sort of general
conceptions one is to keep people from
harming from from wronging from injuring
each other that's one of the things that
justice ought to do but he tells us as
well that justice ought to lead people
to use the common property for common
interests and and this is what we can
often talk about in another way as
common good there are there are things
that we look at as belonging to all of
us you know examples of this would would
include say
city property right or the air that
we're breathing and what will come back
to that in a moment we're gonna look at
each of these in turn he also talks
about the need to maintain truth and
fidelity in agreements that this is
another part of of justice and then he
also distinguishes between harming
others and prevent and allowing others
to be harmed so if we're really just we
also prevent other people from being
harmed it's not enough just that we keep
ourselves from harming them we also
don't let other people harm them and the
final thing that he talks about and and
devotes a lot of space to this in terms
of war is there there have to be certain
limits to whatever retribution or
punishment we impose and even to combat
to war itself with people who declare
themselves our enemies either by word or
by actions so let's talk about each of
these in turn a little bit he says the
first office of justice is to keep one
person from doing harm to another and
there's a very important provision here
unless provoked to by wrong right so you
know there could be cases where if the
other person is wrong in us we actually
do have to harm the other person's self
defense would be be a great example
cases where we have to redress some sort
of thing that has been imposed on us and
we don't have the time to wait for the
authorities to to come along and then he
talks about common property he says
there that really there is no such thing
as private ownership established by
nature but private property becomes
private either through long occupancy or
by due process of law bargain purchase
or allotment and and so Cicero looks at
private property as being something kind
of special it's not something that we
just automatically assume everything all
is from the very beginning rather things
are
is a fairly typical way of looking at
property in ancient world things are
originally sort of common to all the
human beings in the world and they they
all have a share in it and then it gets
set aside set apart for specific reasons
and this places limits on private
property right so he says we're not born
for ourselves alone our country claims a
share of our being and our friends a
share and since as the Stoics hold
everything the earth produces is created
for human beings use and human beings
are born for the sake of other human
beings they might be able to help each
other this is all part of what it means
to be genuinely just according to Cicero
and according to the Stoics so this is
an important conception maintaining
truth and fidelity
he says the foundation of justice is
good faith fides right the word that we
get faith and it can also be translated
as loyalty in a certain set of contexts
as well so he says this means truth and
fidelity news is the word truth here
Veritas and fidelity Constantia we
sometimes say constancy following
through on things doing that in in
relation to agreements convent convent
or convent autumn Quay
he says here and conventions and in
agreements and promises so that's an
important part of justice preventing
harm to others this is something we'll
have to talk about much more at length
he says that it's not enough just to
observe these rules if you see somebody
being harmed and you can actually
prevent that harm you actually do have a
duty to prevent that harm and if you
don't you're actually unjust you're not
just simply by saying well you know no
harm no foul on my part I didn't do
anything to help them but I didn't do
anything to hurt them either no you
actually have to stand in the way of
others being harmed and then finally the
last part we we talked about already
Cicero says
it's not anything goes if you're engaged
in say self-defense that doesn't mean
that you can do anything you like to the
person who is trying to break into your
property or to threaten your life there
are certain limits that you you should
not pass even with enemies in wartime
and Cicero gets very explicit about this
in some interesting discussions what we
see here is you might say the beginnings
of what later comes to be called Just
War Theory all of this is wrapped up in
justice as Cicero conceives of it as
this second source of our duties our
second source of how we align ourselves
to what is genuinely right
you